It's peaceful, isn't
it? By the time I can remember, scenes like this only existed in photographs and videos
World War III My
fathers were considered an anti-government organization for developing the time machine
Daru and Tomoki-san  And were the three of us running away?
Mom died in a strafing while trying to protect me from a military drone, so I want
to see Ka-san getting torn to shreds.
The only destination of war is hell
Time machine Countries fight over wars Many people die This
is a world filled with nothing but fear and despair The lives of 5.7 billion people speak
Uchiyama I've been adrift in world wars many times
Ah,
that's not the case 1,000 people in the world People whose fates are tossed by the time machine I
've even seen one of your conjunctiva I
've repeated everything over and over
[Music]
And I know there's a limit to what people can do I
'm helpless no matter what I do
I've already supported the world
war You said that
Uncle, you can't even change the past and change the world  To move is to deviate from our system It's not a
matter of
human intervention It's God's realm I
'm sure I'll be punished A cruel fate A painful punishment
That's the answer
Uh
[music] There's
still time
[music]
Think again
I wo
n't give up